foreign
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
our Pismo gonna censor tonight the
dreadish sensitivity readers who rancite
Roald Dahl now turn their wicked gaze
onto the Beano to teaching children that
everything is offensive be one of the
reasons why they're all now so anxious
will debate
fears of an AI Takeover in Hollywood is
about the biggest actor strike in
decades now there are plans for an IRS
scanning Global AI Bank should we be
afraid to the biggest human brains in
the business will join me live
plus they're the viral pranksters
winning hearts and Minds by playing just
stop oil cretins at their own irritating
grain game we'll reveal the creators
behind just stop being everyone off
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is Morgan uncensored well good
evening welcome to Piers Morgan
uncensored live from London sounds very
difficult to be young in today's world
barely a day passes without stories of
profound woe amongst our youth kids
mental health is in crisis we're told
anxiety and depression rampant among
children there's even a child anxiety
epidemic right here in the UK apparently
it all sounds very alarming it's also a
bit confusing because generally speaking
the world is getting more prosperous
less poor safer there are fewer Wars uh
people are living longer and healthier
it should be that young people feel
quite happy actually now that we've come
through the pandemic they should be but
they're not and social media probably
has a lot to do with that an entire
Digital World of vipers exists where
self-esteem can be measured directly in
lights even I would worry about that if
I wasn't well so well liked but perhaps
there's a bigger problem here and it's
us we ghastly adults at some point
decided we should teach children to be
mortally offended by everyone and
utterly terrified of everything and that
they could win it everything
and never lose
fresh from ransack enrolled Dial's
legendary children's stories so-called
sensitivity readers God that phrase just
fills my skin with horror doesn't it
yours it might you just literally
sensitivity readers I've now said about
canceling you guessed it this
is
[Music]
spotty what are you doing in my pea soup
I used to love the bastard kids and the
those mischievous little Rogues
in Britain's best love comic book
they were always problematic it's why I
like them I like them being problematic
they've entertained children for 67
years without complaint you know what
kids can be problematic I've had four of
them the Consultants from inclusive
Minds
the very same people who censor Roald
Dahl's books have quietly decided there
needs to be some changes of course I do
the B now now takes professional advice
from this Committee of fun police which
has helped to Rebrand its characters and
vet its back catalog
spotty it was called spotty because he's
spotty is now known as Scotty he's still
got spots you just can't say it and
fatty it was called fatty because he's
fatty is now known as Freddy even though
he's still fat
we just can't call him that the kids
have been joined by five new pupils
doing harsher Mahira and mandira in
order to be more inclusive mandira's
featured in storylines about mental
health to apparently highlight the
anxieties facing children perhaps I
should do one about mandira being warned
that her friend fatty is offensive this
is from the same set of geniuses who
changed Cloud men to Cloud people in
James and the Giant Peach and decided
the black tractors in Fantastic Mr Fox
could not be described as black because
it was potentially racist to other
tractors presumably now there are two
points here the first is about
censorship if we continue to rewrite
every work of fiction based on today's
sensibilities you have to keep doing it
every 10 years until you're left with a
sanitized slab of nonsense that Bears
Zero resemblance to the original
the context of when something was
written as part of what makes it
informative and interesting
the second point is this we have a lot
less about child anxiety when fatty and
spotty were on the loose because they
were considered to be funny then it was
a joke it's a cartoon
if we genuinely want our kids to feel
happier and less anxious maybe we should
stop teaching them constantly that the
entire world is out to get them show
them how to be less offended by
absolutely everything stop allowing them
to all get a prize in everything they
compete in at school so they all think
that they're winners when sometimes
they're not because none of that is a
proper preparation for the real world
the one that in Barbie land is such a
shock to Margot Robbie when she gets to
it the real world I'm afraid is Watson
all it can be tough out there
so why don't we prepare kids
for how to handle it rather than cover
them and cut more well I'm joined Now by
broadcaster former brexit MEP Alex
Phillips talked to be contributor lawyer
Paul around Adrian a political
journalist Ava Santina all right
um Alex
I I brought up four kids
I'm not perfect by any means something
nearly perfect does a father probably
um but
desanitizing of everything this over
protection there's wrapping in Cotton
wool this nobody can lose nobody can be
called any funny names in cartoons blah
blah blah it's exhausting and B all it
seems to be doing is increasing the
amount of anxiety in kids all the
figures show The Situation's getting
worse not better I would argue this
strategy hasn't worked it's had the
opposite effect yeah it's utter Madness
I mean what we seem to be doing as a
society now is making our kids into
little hypochondriacs to worry about
everything to police their own language
at the time they should be learning how
to develop their communication skills to
see everything through the prism of race
to see everything through the prism of
gender and then at the same time the
things perhaps we should protect them
from adults fetish pornography we're
we're foisting upon them at an alarming
rate and I don't understand what
children are supposed to be anymore are
they supposed to engage with this Adult
World of critical race Theory and
extreme adult content 100 genders yeah
there is no more innocence safeguarding
has gone out the window all right Paula
we've discussed a lot of these issues
all right and I get that some kids are
anxious I've met quite a few kids who
have a lot of anxiety problems I think a
lot of it is social media driven I think
a lot of it is dopamine driven that
they're exposed through social media to
a constant barrage of imagery from walls
and other things which we simply would
never see when I was a kid so I think
that cannot be overlooked this constant
sensory overload impacting negatively
and yet all the statistics will show
young people if they calmly explained
there's never been a better time to be
alive actually but the statistics will
also tell you peers about the suicide
rate amongst children about how their
mental health is suffering about how
children are being bullied both
personally and online in the social
World social media world and so when we
look at the bino what surprised me about
this story is that we weren't applauding
what the bino were doing we weren't you
know saying we weren't championing what
they were doing which is to stop
children from calling each other names
because that's not appropriate what do
you think he's going to stop because the
Beano stops using names but well yes I
do actually because it's teaching
children that it's not appropriate and
you call somebody by their name which is
Frank John pauler or Alex you don't call
them spotty you don't call them
you don't call them fatty you call them
by their name and say what you are doing
by but what The Beano is doing is
acknowledging that it's anachronistic in
its style and that it shouldn't be that
it should be taking responsibility for
providing a positive message for
children stop being mean children yeah
but the trouble is life is tough Ava
life is very mean you know I always
remind people of the Rocky Balboa speech
to his son who's a spoiled entitled brat
in the sixth movie and eventually Rocky
loses it with him in the street and says
look life is hard it will beat you down
right and the challenge of succeeding in
life is how many times you can get back
up and keep moving forward it's not how
hard you can punch it's about how hard
you can get punched and keep going we
know this and I my argument is I think
we're just not preparing kids properly
for the real world and and trying to
create this kind of Barbie style Utopia
where no one's mean no one uses mean
words all that kind of thing means you
basically have to airbrush now every
work of literature going back in history
because it was all full of mean stuff it
was it was from Roald Dahl to the B note
they're all getting censored I don't get
it I don't get any of it works I think
it's quite obvious that parents probably
don't want to sit down in 2023 and read
a bedtime story to their child about you
know fatty and spotty I think it's
probably I do hang on I think it's
probably I do forces that have dictated
it and you love the free market and I
think they've probably looked at it and
gone do you know what bino not really
being consumed anymore why don't we try
to get this you know somehow purchased
and back in schools back at bedtime and
that's that's how they've respond let me
throw this back at you my daughter
killed she's 11. she calls me fancy all
the time right and does this to me all
the time good it makes me go to the gym
it's another this morning I was actually
very very different I was actually
Barbie pressing this morning to to
female trainers I mean this is how I how
I flow but the point is I'm not offended
when she does that I think it's funny
right it used to be you could laugh at
stuff like that but what we're now in
we're now in a world where Cosmopolitan
magazine one of the most influential
magazines for young women in this
country but it's a 305 pound model model
on the front cover and doesn't mention
anywhere in the text it either on the
cover or inside that this is more biddly
obese and very dangerous okay it said we
celebrate being incredibly fat but if
you dare to use the word fatty in The
Beano about a fictitious character all
hell breaks loose the sensitivity
bullies get called in it all has to be
changed explain to me how that is good
for society or good for the well-being
of young women who think that being 305
pounds when you're five foot two is a
great thing thing to be is body positive
okay because no one's got the gumption
to go sorry you are morbidly obese
you're gonna die and by the way if you
all want to be this fat you're all going
to die too but then we should have done
that for the models who are 80 pounds
and six foot tall who were on magazines
for 20 years and gave you know the whole
world eating I said the same thing about
the size zero campaign there was never
any warning on there of how women
achieved that body frame no one ever
talked about the smoking never no one
ever talked about the drug taking or the
excessive dieting none of that ever
appeared in a magazine and because I
guarantee your daughter when she calls
you fatty and you have that lovely
little inside Journey as loud as you
can't but when you have a good joke
about it and you're having you know this
nice lovely moment I guarantee you
didn't teach her that word that's
probably something she's picked up and
now you enjoy and you have a nice life
she's teaching that because actually
kids do that kind of thing they're kids
right they're not going to stop because
the B nose changes everyone's name you
taught her that word wouldn't it if you
were at bedtime and you taught her that
word from the be no book that would be a
bit
I've tried to teach my all my kids just
don't worry about you know my mother
always told me you know we talk about
the patriarchy I lived in a matriarchy
with these wonderfully strong women in
my family my grandmother my mother my
sister my daughter's inheriting the same
thing and it's just that sticks and
stones will break your bones not words
will never hurt you come on you're very
much say never mind Sticks and Stones
words are far worse they're not they're
literally not cheers and you know that
that's not true I do not know it's true
I think that's a really dangerous Theory
to push know that words hurt we know
that because our law recognizes that
fact that people are often mistreated
with words and that it can impact on
their lives we know that bullying which
doesn't have to include physical attacks
when we're talking about a verbal
assault on somebody can often have the
same threatening and intimidating effect
as it could if you were physically
assorted I know but my point is if you
say I know well then if you say you know
them we need to acknowledge is watching
this you think it's appropriate to stand
over a partner and Shout abuse at them
in their face or to even worship or to
even whisper it in there no there's any
viewers because my viewers are not those
sort of people uh let's oh absolutely I
would hope I'd hope that they're not
have a Discerning audience
um
recognizes that abuse can be verbal as
well you're never going to persuade me
that verbal uh mockery and stupid
phrases is ever going to come close to
physical violence or maybe Meghan Markle
might be able to do that Meghan Markle
dishes it out like everyone I've ever
seen in my life she thinks it's finally
called the royal family a bunch of
horrible racist scumbags and make
hundreds of millions of dollars you
never complain when she does that but or
you only can play any people say how
disgusting you say that that is not
appropriate and that's exactly the
example that I wanted you to no you're
missing my point completely appropriate
abuse language
what about teaching people to just State
the bleeding obvious so uh in the
Women's World Cup it's called The
Women's World Cup we have a new
Superstar the Canada midfielder Quinn
goes by the name Quinn wasn't the name
that Quinn was born with but Quinn has
been heralded celebrated this week as
the first transgender non-binary
footballer to play in the Women's World
Cup to which my response when I read
this was I got a second hang on
is she a bot is she they whatever is she
a biological male no no turned out she's
a biological female she say so what is
she well whatever they'd like to go
let's go hang on I think I'll quit say
and Quinn I've asked I haven't asked the
question yet she's a
they she is a transgender non-binary
what is that well how can you be
transgender and non-binary because
that's what they are but non-binary men
you were neither one nor the other Queen
also is is I think I'm sorry so I
thought transgender meant you you
literally okay male to female female to
male turns out the non-binary is not the
same as transition I don't want to put
words in their mouth but I would say
that's probably because they're not
allowed to take the correct amount of
testosterone because they are still
playing in the women's team and so I
would assume that they are saying
testosterone doesn't want to be okay
that's what I'm saying Quinn doesn't
want to be made because Quinn can't
compete Queen is he female playing
against females but now doesn't want to
identify because she won't let her play
on the male team no no
she doesn't want to play on the male
team she's not actually they might Quinn
might like know that Quinn wants to be a
an ex-woman Alex
stop being mean by interrupting I'm
coming I'm coming to Alex
I just want to get my head around this
he's a transgender non-binary ex-woman
so my question is if you're no longer
identifying as a woman what are you
doing playing in the Women's World Cup
not my title that is the official title
of a tournament she doesn't qualify they
they don't qualify even there's only one
of them they don't qualify for the
Women's World Cup because they used to
be a woman but now they don't want to be
a woman so now we have to call them they
for being a transgender even though
they're non-binary and they're still
playing in the Women's World Cup and
we're all supposed to go well done Quinn
what a moment
no one's quite sure what we're
celebrating when Alex what are we
celebrating rules change all the time
it's like we're bestowing upon people
who have gender dysphoria some sort of
magical extra special power that normal
people don't have and I don't care
frankly how many scores have they how
many goals have they scored you know
that's more interesting if you're a
professional Paula why is somebody why
someone who doesn't consider themselves
a woman in the woman as well come
explain to me because where else are
they going to be able in a trans or
non-binary tournament I don't see one
and I certainly don't I keep being told
there are millions I keep being told
there are millions of trans people well
great have your own so appears if you
and I want to set one up then I'm I'm
all for that swimming I've just done it
today fantastic so why don't we do that
right instead of being you except they
shouldn't be competing no I do not in
Queenstown no I do not expect me what
options did this person have none was my
answer none no options did this person
yes to perform on their works
you both know this is such no you do be
angry people look at your faces
why are you not angry why are you not
angry to protect and Applause why don't
you want to protect women why is it
always left to me to protect women
aren't protected they're not this person
has gone and they've won an Olympic
medal and now they are playing
successfully doesn't want to be a woman
I don't see what the problem is
my understanding is they've not had any
sort of testosterone so there's no
biological
thing in in the sport yes I don't care
stop telling us all about your great
moves to be a transgender non-binary
whatever nobody cares
um tell me what I do care about the boss
of NatWest Alison Rose has now admitted
in this Nigel farage Coots Bank Fiasco a
serious error of judgment turns out she
admits she sat next to the top BBC
journalist the night before the BBC
journalist tweets the real story about
Nigel farage is that actually it wasn't
to do with his political views that he
was removed from a Coots account it was
because of his financial situation turns
out to be a total lie because Nigel far
has got under the data rules he got all
the minutes from the meeting where it
was clearly his his political views Ava
whichever side you're on on this
politically makes no difference to me
I've got no truck to support farage at
all he's trying to stiff me over Donald
Trump as I've said as I said he's got a
lot of pain coming his way for that so
that's a different huge rumbling away
however on this I'm a
today and I said right come on have you
got one of these on me and I was told
I'm not a politically whatever it is
person so they haven't they assured me
but they've had a lot of calls from
clients asking am I am I next for this
right what have you got on me is it my
political views what are you holding on
me this is not right in a democracy like
this that people's political opinions
lead to them having their bank account
canceled it's just not okay let's just
can we make one thing Crystal Clear
which is that Coots is a very selective
bank so it you know Nigel farage was
offered a bank account with now not with
Coots he wasn't going to be just thrown
out I mean I can't go and get a bank
account with Coots you know they are
very selective and but but however her
briefing the CEO briefing uh the BBC
business journalist is apps
extraordinary I mean I mean to me I
can't understand how you can talk about
someone's Financial matter totally agree
I don't understand hold on that alone
it's just a massive breach of his
business and I have to say and it's it's
on the record now you called it last
week peers right when we discussed this
you did yeah um and you're absolutely
right to have said what you did last
week because it makes it it's just
uncomfortable whichever way you look at
it completely wrong whether it's
somebody in the street or Nigel farage
or the queen I mean the queen used to
back down the street though let's talk
about this in proportion because
I read through every word of of their
meeting and Alex the truth is you know
Nigel well the truth is there was
nothing in there other than apparently
he knew Donald Trump he liked Novak
djokovic's tweet I mean the whole thing
was ridiculous but I mean it's a
personal Vendetta isn't it and the
problem and what we've actually found
out since Nigel told the world about
this story is this is happening to
countless normal people yeah and it's
it's it's really quite dystopian it's
worrying it's like the Chinese social
credit system believe what we believe or
you can't have access also you've got to
trust your bank right how can somebody
who runs one of the biggest banks in the
country brief to a journalist inaccurate
serious information
which is that the reason that some
people are being turned away from Banks
now is because they want to deal in cash
and Banks no longer want to deal in cash
that is entirely different from
political views we've got two different
stories here that are getting a little
bit that's a different issue no but if
we're going to say that we should clear
issue here is if you have certain
opinions it should not be down to a bank
to decide your opinions don't suit their
values it's nonsense
to be fair I do get to choose who I bank
with so for example I'm aware of One
bank I think it's the cooperative bank
if they still do that we're very clear
around an advertising campaign about how
they would invest your money
um in environmentally friendly for
example projects that's a good thing and
I can choose whether I want to bankrupt
the co-op or not they should also have
the opportunity to decide whether they
want me as well hold on if this was if
this is when this is on the other foot
the bakery in Ireland says I don't want
to bake again oh hell broke loose
if we're talking about race
by the way this will happen to Jeremy
here this happened to Jeremy corbyn yeah
man just imagine what would have
happened if kutzer said I don't want to
bank with you because you're white or I
don't want to bank or you do you to bank
with us because you're gay then of
course we're having a different
conversation
[Music]
to that case all right
agreed though that this boss should
probably not be in her job yeah she
should Shuffle up that's definitely it's
definitely a grievance issue and I'll be
agree that as a result uh unlike the
theme of Barbie women shouldn't really
be put in top jobs because they just
they just can't be trusted
[Applause]
because when I'm with my Village mates
we do sometimes if somebody crosses a
line it's inappropriate someone will go
may come on it is actually quite a good
little certainly in The Villages mates
come on you're defending yeah I've
agreed with him twice running last night
about pollution he's bang on about
pollution ever since he got air purifies
on my house I'm a different Beast yeah
honestly yeah transformed my health just
living in a very polluted area in London
I now have air purifiers don't go out
when the Air's bad and and I feel great
and I tell everyone is out there he's
got problems with red eyes streaming
signers all that stuff you think may be
hay fever I bet it's pollution go and
get air purifiers shut the windows only
go out when your app tells you to trust
me you'll feel exactly like I do I'm
gonna get pairs of just stop oil
right thank you good to see you I said
next that's impressed Officer Nick Clegg
says artificial intelligence is too
stupid to take over the world and we
should leave it all in their capable
hands which sounds to me like an
incredibly stupid thing to be saying my
next guest says it's like an atomic bomb
and we're in a new Cuban Missile Crisis
and I suspect he knows a bit more about
it than Nick Clegg we'll debate this
after the break
[Music]
good evening I'm Peters Morgan I'm
censored in New York City tonight on
Piers Morgan uncensored in Kiev Ukraine
tonight on Piers Morgan's Special
Edition from cancer tonight a special
edition appears more than uncensored
Martinez he's making me cry again do you
believe you can win this war so are you
gonna run again I think a lot of people
are going to be very happy yes I feel
betrayed they're trying to force you out
yes not only the coach but the other two
or three guys there around these
protesting just don't get many of them
don't it's not slightly patronizing
I would call it beautiful out the window
do you think we should have psychiatric
assessments I'd be there for three weeks
did you keep quiet I'm trying to read
the book
takes bear and Chuck it where it belongs
in the bin
sexy where are they where's their
children
Max will agree to be interviewed for the
very first time I obviously wish I'd
never met him your shape your head the
British people are up in arms Boris
Johnson is out as British prime minister
the conservative party can certainly win
the next election can we yes
can we this is the Royal team question
is did he say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules to give them the
Visa or lied on the visa application
form and therefore got it
[Music]
what is a woman me
let it roll a woman is given to the man
in marriage Andrew You're simply wrong
I've been a terrible liar that's true I
mean would you be prepared to say that
I've been a terrible liar are you sorry
you said that
it matters you should absolutely not you
should be interview adjourned
which is your favorite nickname that
Trump's giving us Rhonda sanctimonious
or meatball Rock I've seen you clown
Tommy Fury so please go easy on me bro
please go easy you weren't asked to give
evidence to the grand jury I have
nothing to hire I'm the only one that
has been telling the troops if you had
to come up against a team that had a
Russian player would you shake that no
chance no chance it's life and death
This Is War Pass Morgan
what went wrong she said well I've only
got two years and I said you'll have two
months if you carry on like this what's
your response to him the whole nation
deserves to know what happened you don't
drink never taken drugs you're stinking
Rich should we be concerned
real opinions real debate is about you
and your opinions if you're thinking
about it we're talking about it
it's all about me that was a joke
[Music]
welcome back to Pittsburgh uncensored AI
threatens to radically reshape the world
economy in the increasingly near future
Hollywood too is on guard the perceived
threat of AI has driven both writers and
actors to walk out in their first double
strike for more than 60 years and today
chat GPT founder Sam Altman unveiled a
Global Currency which gives out digital
coins in exchange for a scan of the
eyeballs it all sounds very futuristic
and quite alarming doesn't it well not
according to meta press Officer Nick
Clegg you might remember him used to be
a politician here who says that AI is
actually very stupid and we should let
companies like his Facebook meta just
get on with it
um I think a lot of the sort of
existential warnings the warnings of
existential threats relate to models
that don't currently exist so-called
super intelligent you know super
powerful AI models the models that we're
open sourcing are far far short of that
in fact
in many ways they're quite stupid
really well joining me to discuss the
issue is the former Google ex-chief
business office at Mo gordat and the
Godfather of virtual reality Jaron Lani
well welcome to both of you all right Mo
apparently
is stupid AI nothing to worry about I'll
just see here I mean in a very
interesting way it's not there yet but
the question is when will it get to
Super intelligence is what most AI
developers will not talk isn't it stupid
though to think right now that it's
stupid absolutely I mean in in the the
when we when we met last time I told you
that GPT today is 155 IQ that's compared
to Einstein at 160. but the stupidity
comes from the types of intelligence
because when you really understand that
intelligence is not just IQ you need EQ
emotional intelligence or empathy you
need the you know creativity and tuition
and so on and AI today is being
developed by a bunch of very masculine
developers sitting somewhere talking
about IQ iqiq and when you really think
about it what destroyed our world or got
us to where we are today in climate
change and other topics is that we're so
dependent on IQ and we have no empathy
to the planet no empathy to other beings
it's uh it's put that on steroids and we
could be in a very dangerous place John
Lonnie in a recent survey 42 percent of
CEO said I could destroy Humanity in
five to ten years
I mean do you share anything like that
kind of view if it got out of hand
well
it wouldn't be AI destroying Humanity it
would be us destroying ourselves like
the the real issue is whether we become
stupid and unfortunately we can use
computer software to make ourselves
stupid we do it on social media all the
time every day uh and you know really
all AI is at least the kind of AI that
we're building now is a mashup of what
people put into it uh one person puts in
a picture of a cat another person puts
in a certain style of painting and you
say can I get that cat as painted by
that person and that's the kind of thing
we can do and that's great it has a lot
of uses
but the danger is that we perceive it as
being much more than that and we put uh
indeed a stupid thing in control and you
know my response to Nick Clegg is that a
stupid adversary can be much more
dangerous than a smart adversary you
know and so just saying talk about
whether it's stupid or smart in a way
doesn't help us you know like that's not
the main issue the question is are we
stupid or smart and um I'm a little
concerned that we're just giving
we're creating this almost like this
religion around AI is this new super
being and I think doing that makes us
stupid I think that's the core of the
problem
what should we be doing then without how
should we be positioning it treating it
well I think we should look at the real
scenarios for harm that are possible and
the one right now
that I think is the most likely is not
so much that the AI will break out of a
jail and take over all the weapons and
kill us which we've seen in the movies
many times like in The Terminator movies
um I think the greater danger is that
will overwhelm ourselves with deep fakes
and nonsense and personally tailored
propaganda maybe at a crucial moment
when we can least afford it
um I I hate to say this but like the
scenario that really bugs me is that
um we currently have a situation where
the main social media platform that
young people use is called Tick Tock and
it's ultimately controlled by China and
I don't want to lose myself to paranoia
over China uh but it is true that
there's a plausible scenario where we
end up in a a conflict with them and if
that day comes they'll have all this
data about every all the kids of key
people in the military and Industry and
government they're the Interiors of
their homes
it's not quite economic yet to do it but
before too long they might be able to
create massive
highly uh personalized and tailored deep
fakes that just um yeah stress everyone
out and then you lose 20 minutes until
you figure out it's a fake but that's
the crucial question I think that's I
think you'll spot on because Tick Tock
is the number one use Source now for
most young people uh Mo just trying to
be positive as well as looking at the
kind of potential horrific downside of
this take things like disease heart
disease cancer things like this which
humans have really struggled to conquer
how fast could AI
find a cure for all cancers for example
I mean how realistic is it that AI can
do that job infinitely better than
humans definitely faster than humans and
definitely fast it's the question which
I agree 100 the the it's we can be
stupid the the reality of humanity is
that uh capitalism doesn't make them the
larger amounts of money from helping
others uh you know capitalism makes
larger amounts of money uh from
patenting uh medicine in a way or
creating weapons and so on and so forth
It's the idea of us using intelligence
in the right way requires us to believe
that there is going to be an abundance
that's sufficient for all of us so that
we don't need to compete for those
limited resources but have you heard of
for example ai's work in medicine and
Science Now beginning to really
accelerate in a beneficial way because
people will watch this and these
conversations terrify people right I
mean you know you hear people as eminent
an expert as you two talking about what
could happen with it it's pretty scary
it's infinitely I always say it's a
singularity we we have the potential to
create a Utopia and also the potential
to mess it up right and it is infinitely
a big gift for Humanity if we were able
to use this kind of intelligence
intelligence has no inherent negative
value in it it can solve all of the
problems we're facing it can help us you
know reverse climate change that can
help us with diseases can help us with
human connection it can help us with
abundance in general and I think it's
definitely something that world leaders
to need to come together and say let's
put our differences aside and and work
on General how do we stop nefarious
forces seizing ultimate control of AI
yeah so you know in my opinion what
happened is that when we built up the
internet
uh we had an almost an ideology that we
wanted the internet to be kind of
mysterious we wanted it to feel like
this Oracle giving us information
and so we created an internet where you
never knew where something came from it
all came from people but we don't know
where and so now we're paying the price
for that uh wanting that sense of an
oracle by having an AI that we don't
understand and it's uh it's a little bit
of a dumb problem we created for
ourselves if we keep track of where the
examples are from people that went into
the AI and then keep track of which
examples were the most important every
time the AI does something then all of a
sudden it'll become clear what's a deep
fake what's from a reliable source
what's propaganda what's just
incompetent or silly like we have to be
able to illuminate the humans and what
the humans are doing in order to
understand what the machine built and
operated by the humans is doing yeah if
we try to treat the machine as just like
this m entity that's supposed to make
sense by itself then there's really no
possibility of understanding it because
by definition we've chosen to be blind
to it so we can basically make our AI
what we choose to make it and the
question is are we going to have the
courage and the strength and the
intelligence to make it a false for good
not bad uh gentlemen thank you both very
much indeed fascinating debate and we'll
keep having it I'll be probably seeing
you every two months because that's how
fast the story moves you know absolutely
it's an honor thank you on says the next
claims and gutter Politics on both sides
of Atlantic Trump support as opposed to
a remarkable Attack video is it one of
the worst attack videos ever seen well
Frank Lonesome I guess thinks it might
be that's next
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
welcome back to peers organizer prime
minister Rishi sunak has today been
accusing gutter politics after
personally posting an attack ad tweet
which claimed labors on the same side as
criminal gangs smuggling migrants into
Britain the labor itself was accused of
the same thing after a viral marketing
campaign accused soon Act of not
believing abusers should go to jail and
if you think we've got it bad take a
look at this conspiracy Laden video
posted in America today the video is
posted by an arms length Group which
makes viral pro-trump content and Trump
often shares their videos
if I was the Deep State and I wanted to
destroy America
I would rig the election with a puppet
candidate I would create a false flag
that allows for mail-in ballots
I would be in charge of the ballot
counting machines
I would create a false flag to blame all
who question the results of the election
I would make sure all crimes I ever
committed never happened I would
prosecute my biggest competition I would
make sure they could never run for
office ever again I would push my
pedophilia Ambitions on you
well that goes over several minutes uh
along the same lines are these the new
moral battle field of which next year's
elections are set to be for joining me
now is political strategist is polls to
Franklin's and Donald Trump's Pastor
Mark Burns welcome to both of you
Franklin's um you tweeted this the most
alarming political ad you've seen this
year why
I I still don't know how to describe it
I don't know how to respond I was so
stunned at how divisive how negative and
how it's designed to create anxiety and
fear and and genuine dislike and
distrusted people pierce at some points
you have to say enough is enough and
I'll be curious to hear from the pastor
okay when he counsels the former
president is this really who we are as a
people is this really who we are as a
country does this add or detract from
our political discourse it's getting
worse and worse and this ad right in the
living hell out of me so I expect you're
going to see a lot of it as a result
right so Pastor Burns I mean I watched
it and it just is this is what I call
Rabbit Hole conspiracy theory claptrap
masquerading as mainstream politics I
mean surely you wouldn't defend a lot of
what you heard and saw in that in that
commercial would you well Pierce let me
just say this uh there's a reason why uh
president Donald Trump is leading in the
polls on Statewide there's a reason he's
leading in the polls uh nationally
there's a reason why um he is still the
front runner even though you had all of
the the fraudulent indictments um that
are coming against them uh you know I
can't led by the Biden and his uh doj
which has been weaponized to essentially
interfere with an election uh there's a
reason why the American people are still
choosing Donald Trump because he is
literally the modern day Julius Caesar
right it was the Senators the elite that
killed off uh Julius Caesar it wasn't
the Common Man Donald Trump speaks to
the Common Man and that's why he's
I've been a two-tier system in America
and they're tied up being led by people
like Joe Biden and the Biden crime in
relation to what Frank just said is it
healthy for America or American politics
or American democracy that you have such
a nihilistic ad like this flying around
social media such a dystopian look at
the country you know America was built
on Unity of a country that was welcoming
to all that fought together to become
the greatest country on Earth this kind
of thing looks to me like it's an
incredibly divisive attempt to brush off
everything that's negative about Trump
is absolutely invented by the Deep state
they're all out to get him he's Julius
Caesar the knives are flying in his back
it could be that you know a lot of the
stuff that Trump's been alleged to have
done is really true they shouldn't have
done it we'll find out in the court
cases but why would you as if Pastor
be happy for such overt negativity to be
swarming around America
well Frank uh what what is truthful and
you hit it right on the nail that the
American Revolution took place because
the people came together for truth like
we had no representation right in
England so the people came together
because of Truth fact and the fact is
right now we have a a government uh um
that is pushing a a doj to be
weaponizing against Donald Trump number
two we are changing sexes in America
there's a reason why Donald Trump is is
touching the Christian Community by
saying that he would not allow grown men
to participate in female sports the fact
that we're questioning the identity of
biology male what is a male what is a
female but not questioning Pfizer not
questioning the the covet vaccines that
has literally dumb harm that's not
conspiracy people are actually in the
ground right that is not a conspirations
die so the American people peers want
truth American people want fact they I
want to be killed in the dark anymore
yeah I don't think a pastor should be
saying that the only thing the covid
vaccines did was Jesus
I don't think a pastor should be saying
the only purpose
had to deal with the Roman season Jesus
himself has to deal with those who spoke
this is my church
my church not yours I don't think it's
because Jesus
faster what you've just said about Kobe
vaccines was not the truth yes you had
some adverse side effects but yes
actually it saved a lot of millions of
people from going under the ground
Franklin's um what do you do when you
have Donald Trump's own Pastor who signs
up on all this stuff and thinks that
actually it's all true
you ask your question rather than make a
statement is this the proper discourse
that we should be having on your show
is this the kind of behavior that we
should be emulating for your children
are these the priorities are kids
learning what they need to know to be
successful in University career in life
are is this the right approach my my
challenge in this is that I don't
necessarily disagree with a lot of the
points either raised by the pastor or
raised by the ad it's how it's done and
peers I've come my entire career I've
suddenly figured out that there's some
things more important than the election
decency civility respect these are
values that a good country Champions and
we're losing them in America and one
last point
we don't have to demonize each other to
prove that we ourselves are correct it
doesn't require the destruction of the
opposition or not the enemy the
destruction of the opposition to promote
the things that we promote and here's
the truth you've always stood for and
I'm sorry for this conversation because
frankly it's an embarrassment yeah
Pastor all I would say to you Pastor is
your job as a pastor surely is to bring
people together not to fuel Division and
when the truth when you speak yeah but
your idea of what the truth is and mine
might be different you should be out of
respect the fact that I have a different
opinion to you or the Frank does
okay Pierce so I get all that I hear
what you're saying but the reality of it
is you're ignoring the fact that there
is but two sexes in the world there's
male there's no I agree with you about
it now we have a society otherwise
you're barking up the wrong trees I
agree with you about that Donald Trump
is fighting against this is why he is
leading in the polls this is why he's
raising money because he is God's
anointed and I understand that the
powers that be like yourself are coming
it's not love Frank Frank Lux I love
frank right but but Frank course he you
know as much as I love frank and thank
you Frank my father has got knee surges
you and I had a great conversation years
ago so I love you and I respect you but
you also said that Hillary Clinton was
going to be the next president of the
United States of America so we know that
you don't like anything mag but the
American people do right and the
American people are behind Donald Trump
that's why he's leaving the party
family weaponize the doj listen if we're
going to talk about videos how about you
talk about the status video and his Nazi
imagery
we're not here to talk about the
scientists final word to you Frank make
it quick please we're running out of
time I'm sorry that I did this interview
and I appreciate that the pastor likes
me this is so inappropriate for British
audiences for American audiences and if
this is the direction we're headed in
here's we're gonna have a really bad 18
months yeah I think I agree with you
it's got to be a more civil way to to
debate I totally agree Frank uh good to
see you both though Frank thank you for
joining me Pastor thank you for joining
me maybe got a little easy with the
president Trump next time you see him
tell him to just wins dial things down a
bit dial it down a bit dial down the
rhetoric not everyone has to hate each
other there's different opinions uh good
to see you both thank you on sense of
next the antidote to just stop oil a new
group called just stop peeing everyone
off is taking them on their own game
people behind him will be revealed next
[Music]
all right
good evening I'm Peters Morgan
uncensored in New York City tonight on
Piers Morgan uncensored in Kiev Ukraine
tonight on Piers Morgan on special
edition tonight a special edition
appears more than uncensored Martina
navratulations he's making me cry again
you believe you can win this war so are
you gonna run again I think a lot of
people are going to be very happy yes I
feel betrayed they're trying to force
you out yes not only the coach but the
other two or three guys there around
these protesting just don't get many of
them don't it's not slightly patronizing
I would call it beautiful do you think
we should have psychiatric assessments
I'd be there for weeks did you keep
quiet I'm trying to read the book
takes bear and Chuck it where it belongs
in the bin
Dixie where are they where's their
children
Max will agree to be interviewed for the
very first time I obviously wish I'd
never met him you'll Shake in your head
the British people are up in arms Boris
Johnson is out as British prime minister
the conservative party can certainly win
the next election can we yes
this is the royalty question is did he
say yes I have taken drugs and they bent
the rules to give them the Visa or lied
on the visa application form and
therefore got it
thank you
what does a woman me
let it roll a woman is given to the man
in marriage Andrew You're simply wrong
I've been a terrible liar that's true I
mean would you be prepared to say that
I've been a terrible liar are you sorry
you said that
no nothing it matters you should be
absolutely not you should be interview
adjourned
[Music]
which is your favorite nickname that
Trump's giving us Rhonda sanctimonious
or meatball Rock I've seen you clown
Tommy Fury so please go easy on me bro
you weren't asked to give evidence to
the grand jury I have nothing to hire
I'm the only one that has been telling
the truth if you had to come up against
a team and had a Russian player would
you shake that no chance no chance it's
life and death This is
what went wrong she said well I've only
got two years and I said you'll have two
months if you carry on like this what's
your response to him the whole nation
deserves
you don't drink never taken drugs you're
stinking Rich should we be concerned
real opinions real debate is about you
and your opinions if you're thinking
about it we're talking about it
it's all about me that was a joke
coming up on the talk the banking boss
at the center of the Nigel farage
account closure route admits leaking
personal information about him to the
BBC justop oil racks up a 7 million
pound policing bill in just a few weeks
and a TV executive says shows like Ali G
and Borat wouldn't be allowed to be made
today that's all at nine o'clock
[Music]
welcome back to Facebook on Samsung just
up oil protester become a national
irritation targeting all the things that
we love like sporting events flower
shows and so on one of the latest
processions was so delightfully met by
counter protesters staging an
intervention and the group just stopped
peeing everyone off also infiltrated
adjust stop oil banquet and gloriously
they had balloons which flew around
which had alarms blaring off take a look
oh so fabulous isn't it missing someone
more getting annoyed and irritated just
like they get to irritate and annoy us
so who is behind this and is there more
to come well you'll be unsurprised to
hear perhaps if your regular viewers of
the show that it's my old friends Joshua
Peters and Archie manners who join me
now with the world's top pranksters uh
great effort chaps I was roaring you on
when I first heard about the first one I
thought that's got the mark of my boys
and sure enough it was YouTube
um you've taken me by surprise I didn't
think you'd be a fan of it so I'm really
relieved that you liked it I love it
because they are so annoying and in my
view the manner of their protests has
been completely backfiring because the
public are just seeing people setting
out to deliberately ruin their
day-to-day life that's not how you bring
people on the agenda with you right no
not at all I think we can all agree that
climate change is a very serious issue
and we all know that something needs to
be done but when you're protesting and
campaigning for things you need to bring
people with you and just stop oil are
having the exact opposite effect on the
British public and what you don't need
to do is have a soccer and great big
party on Sunday I mean that doesn't help
that does nothing to help the
environment at all it's just there was a
heart up there was a harpist live music
they're all clinking their single use
have you heard today that just policing
just up oil this year's cost over seven
million pounds now people are going
through a cost of living crisis seven
million pounds to police these idiots
who most of the time are doing idiotic
things I mean the other day they were
blockading a pregnant woman who was had
a uh who then her boyfriend got into a
fight with them I didn't agree with the
violence but I understood why he was so
defensive of his poor pregnant uh
partner another woman had a newborn baby
in the in her car and couldn't take
maybe wherever they were going to go all
this kind of thing is just like to me
it's just moronic it's not achieving
anything and we in order to pull these
pranks off we had a mole inside so we
infiltrated their ranks and we followed
them around for a day before we pulled
any stunts and partly interesting was
talking to the priests men and women who
hundreds of them on Parliament Square
policing this stuff they don't want to
be doing it either no and they're so
irrespective also don't they've got
better things to do more important
things to worry about we all agree
broadly with the calls we just don't
agree with the methodology I don't think
it's changing people's hearts and minds
are you going to carry on doing these
chats I think we'll we'll call it a day
I think we've proved our Point
um look you know I don't think you
should I think
somebody has somebody has taken but just
stopped paying off slogan and whacked it
on a website everywhere they pop up
annoying people you should be annoying
them because on that note we've brought
you a little presence
wear this proud in fact you know you
know who I'm gonna give this to uh my my
eldest son is watching tonight he's big
fans of you two he knows YouTube from
the nightclub scene no no we deny that
he's 30 years old tomorrow which makes
me feel unbelievably old so Spencer uh
if you're wondering what your present is
it's just a ride and I know you'll love
wearing this you can take this to Ibiza
where you're going tomorrow so happy
birthday for tomorrow Happy Birthday 30
year old son my God I never thought that
though he's really panicked about it as
well but I want him to join your group I
think they're a wonderful group to join
uh cheers well done thank you for
restoring a little bit of counter-attack
of his Madness and doing it with your
normal Panache and humor which is the
key I think uh good to see you both
thank you for having us
it for me whatever up to Keep It
Uncensored and remember the key message
tonight is this
just stop
ping everyone off
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign